>>> LCOME BACK TO "STATE OF
THE UNION."
WE COULD SEE AS SOON AS TUESDAY
HOW THE DEMOCRAT STRATEGY IN
WASHINGTON IS PLAYING OUT WITH
VORS.
A CLOSELY FOUGHT GOVERNOR'S RACE
BE A RELATIVELY EASY VICTORY FOR
DEMOCRAT TERRY McAULIFFE WHO HAS
HELD THE JOB BEFORE.
AFTER ALL, JOE BIDEN COMFORTABLY
WON VIRGINIA A YEAR AGO BY TEN
PERCENTAGE POINTS.
AS McAULIFFE PUT HIS EFFORTS
INTO TYING HIS GOP OPPONENT TO
DONALD TRUMP, REPUBLICAN
BUSINESSMAN GLENN YOUNGKIN
SEIZED ON CULTURE WARS AND
PARENTS' FRUSTRATION WITH
SCHOOLS IN VOTER-RICH SUBURBS.
A NEW POLL HAS YOUNGKIN AHEAD.
FOR FIRST-TIME CANDIDATE WHO
STARTED OUT WITH ALMOST NO NAME
RECOGNITION, QUITE A CROWD
GATHERED TO GREAT BUSINESSMAN
GLENN YOUNGKIN, ESPECIALLY FOR
7:30 A.M. ON A SATURDAY.
>> THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> Reporter: THIS IS ALEXANDRIA,
VIRGINIA, WHERE JOE BIDEN WON A
WHOPPING 80% OF THE VOTE JUST
LAST YEAR.
YOUNGKIN IS TAPPING INTO A
POTENT ISSUE ESPECIALLY AMONGST
SUBURBAN VOTERS, EDUCATION.
>> WE WILL HAVE CHOICE IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
>> Reporter: WALKING THE FINEST
OF LINES, APPEALING TO PARENT
FRUSTRATION EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC.
>> SCHOOLS WILL NEVER BE CLOSED
IN, FIVE DAYS IN-PERSON.
>> Reporter: WHILE DIPPING HIS
TOE IN CULTURE WARS AMPLIFIED BY
CONSERATIVE MEDIA.
>> ON DAY ONE I WILL BAN
CRITICAL RACE THEORY FROM BEING
IN OUR SCHOOLS.
>> Reporter: REALITY CHECK,
CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS NOT PART
OF VIRGINIA'S STANDARDS OF
LEARNING, BUT HE KNOWS IT'S AN
ANIMATING ISSUE FOR THE GOP BASE
STILL LOYAL TO DONALD TRUMP, BUT
YOUNGKIN IS WARY OF ALIENATING
INDEPENDENT VOTERS.
IS THIS A REPUBLICAN PLAYBOOK
THAT OTHER GOP CANDIDATES CAN
USE GOING FORWARD IN BLUE
STATES?
>> I REALLY HAVEN'T THOUGHT
ABOUT ANYTHING BEYOND VIRGINIA.
IT FELT LIKE THERE WAS A
DIFFERENT WAY TO RUN A CAMPAIGN.
>> Reporter: KEEPING TRUMP'S
VOTERS ON BOARD, BUT THE MAN
HIMSELF AT A COMFORTABLE
DISTANCE IS THE NAME OF THE GAME
FOR YOUNGKIN IN BLUE VIRGINIA.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT IS EXPECTED
TO PARTICIPATE IN A RALLY HERE
ON MONDAY.
>> I HAVEN'T BEEN INVOLVED.
THE TEAMS ARE TALKING.
>> Reporter: I'M SURE THEY'D
LOVE TO HAVE YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE THERE?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO BE ENGAGED
IN THE TE WILL HE TOWN HALL.
WE HAVE MORE PEOPLE HELPING US
THAN YOU CAN BELIEVE.
>> Reporter: IN RESPONSE, TERRY
McAULIFFE TOLD CNN'S DAN MERICA.
>> THIS ISN'T ABOUT TRUMP.
>> Reporter: UNUSUAL FROM THE
CANDIDATE WHO MADE TYING
YOUNGKIN TO TRUMP THE
CENTERPIECE OF HIS CAMPAIGN.
>> I AM RUNNING AGAINST SOMEONE
WHO HAS BEEN ENDORSED BY DONALD
TRUMP.
DONALD TRUMP AND GLENN YOUNGKIN
ARE TRYING TO RUN DOWN THE
DEMOCRACY OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> MY OPPONENT IS A TRUMP JUANA
BE, ENDORSED BY TRUMP TWO TIMES.
>> I'M GLAD I HAVE TWO CUPS
HERE.
I KEEP DRINKING WHEN YOU MENTION
DONALD TRUMP'S NAME.
>> HAVE YOU MADE THIS RACE ABOUT
TRUMP?
>> HE WANTS TO RUN IN 2024 AND
HE WANTS TO USE DAN AS A LAUNCH
PAD FOR THAT, THAT'S PRETTY
CLEAR.
>> Reporter: McAULIFFE IS TRYING
TO NATIONALIZE THE RACE BRINGING
IN THE BIG GUNS IN THE HOPES OF
ENCOURAGING A COMPLACENT
DEMOCRATIC ELECTORATE TO GO TO
THE POLLS.
>> SHOW UP FOR DEMOCRACY, FOR
VIRGINIA, FOR THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA.
>> Reporter: A CONTRAST YOUNGKIN
IS LEANING INTO.
>> QUIT BRINGING ALL THESE
PEOPLE INTO VIRGINIA.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
WE A